[Musique]
moi je vis et parade juifs ma femme et
l'ashkenaze juive alors on a dû manger
complètement différent quand j'ai
rencontré alex j'avais jamais mangé
autant de nourriture marocaine alors
c'était vraiment évoqué depuis quelques
années beaucoup de jeunes restaurateurs
juifs prennent la cuisine de leur
enfance et la modernité
c'est le cas de rigueur et alex ans
alors j'ai essayé de prendre le manger
que ma femme angers depuis qu'il est
petit et de faire de la façon que moi
j'ai mangé avec tous les épices et un
peu de chose différent alors on a les
immigrants juifs de l'europe place et
qui sont venus à la fin du 19ème siècle
et on les appelle les jeux achetés la c1
qui ont amené le smoke meat des baies
roses des stakes et nous inscrire ce
majeur dans les années 60 il ya une
vague d'immigration de juifs du maroc et
on les appelle les juifs séfarades et
ils ont emmené des saveurs plus
différent comme plus méditerranée
celui-ci
le resteront est en fait dans le musée
du morea juifs 6-1 musique est ouvert
huit ans et il ya deux ans et demi en
ouvert notre espace sur le boulevard
saint-laurent dans le coeur du quartier
historique chef catherine se donne pour
mission de faire découvrir une cuisine
juive rien inventé ici on arrête le
belgo marocain
quand j'ai créé ce plat je voulais
marier les saveurs ashkénazes d'un club
ego traditionnelle avec les saveurs
marocaines le fromage à la crème et
parfumée au citron confit et le saumon
fumé remplacée par une gravlax de saumon
au hazé la note
on y découvre aussi un club sandwich
fait de guy fil des fiches on le fait
maison ici c'est très bon ces hommes du
poisson haché qui est mélangée avec des
oignons qui avait à caraméliser de
l'aneth citron naples a lancé ses fans
et et c'est moderne c'est vraiment très
bon
[Musique]
le vent de renouveau souffle aussi au
restaurant itunes 9 la rencontre de
leurs deux cultures a donné naissance à
de nombreuses variations de plats
traditionnels il à certains des choses
qui sont vraiment en mx2 les deux comme
la soupe aux choux des paiements un
recette de ma grand mère est la
résultante de 100 grammes et juste par
accident un jour on les a mis ensemble
et c'était délicieux et comme son ami
live
non c'est exprès alors moi j'aime
mélanger le manger picon marocain avec
le sucre et ashkénazes et on est venu
avec cette soupe qui est vraiment
quelque chose de spécial c'est costaud
rien ne nous écoute ou maman il y en a
et on a alors premièrement quand tu fais
une fugue mas sabole la chose la plus
importante c'est les boules
ils doivent être chauffée londe avance
la soupe maggio bas un classique
ashkénazes a été réinventée en intégrant
une influence séfarades
boule de masse à la soupe est bonne mais
la boule de massat doute comme presque
rien alors moi je voulais faire un peu
avec de l'oignon dedans avec le gras de
poulet dedans et soft sans lui et ça
vraiment donner quelque chose de
vraiment spécial comme ça c'est la soupe
de matin
[Musique]
là j'étais un peu de beurre et s'est
clarifiée pour les perroquets un peu
voici maintenant les pierrots guy aux
pommes de terre oignons caramélisés
ricotta et carvi déposé sur une purée de
date mais john aromatisé à la cannelle
mexicaine avec un soupçon de crème sûre
alors mi-mollet
et un peu de lait force et c'est tout ça
c'est des parts
c'est un plat qui est pas léger qui est
lourd mais le d'adp s'enlève legras un
peu c'est vraiment délicieuse les
petites piques en dur et fort la texture
de la porte avec un petit peu de femmes
à exact de sucre est exact
après tu me la nature c'est ça ouais
j'aime beaucoup que la cuisine juive est
vraiment une cuisine à diverses et
j'aime aussi le fait que si une cuisine
qui évoluent elles évoluent toujours et
il ya toujours de la place pour créer un
nouveau plat
[Musique]